poor Sara Huckabee Sanders she's upset
that people are calling her a liar and
she also can't seem to stop lying
recently saying that Donald Trump reads
more than anyone she knows the only way
that's true is if no one she knows reads
at all I've talked before about this
issue of what I think is a really
unfortunate rehabilitation of people's
image that will happen after they leave
the Trump administration or even after
they simply are out of power george w
bush being an example of this and one
example under the trump administration
is former Trump's first former press
secretary Sean Spicer who has now seen
much more positively nationally after
participating in that reality show
Dancing with the Stars and no longer
being Donald Trump's daily liar and
chief and this is sad because you know
it's not about grudges or anything like
that but when people are hugely bad
actors who perpetuate a disastrous
agenda run interference for it defend a
nightmarish president and truly bad acts
by that president they shouldn't be
immediately seen as funny great people
because they no longer work for the
President of the United States this
brings us to Donald Trump's second
former press secretary Sarah Huckabee
Sanders who as I've been saying since
the beginning is really one of the most
vile characters from the entire
nightmare that has been the Trump
administration she doesn't like being
called a liar she recently said to the
New York Times quote I was attacked for
everything not just my performance I was
called a fat soccer mom my kids were
threatened my life was threatened it was
a lot I hate harping on it but to be in
the position I'm in and to have Secret
Service that's not normal I don't like
being called a liar the other stuff has
bothered me
far less well one way not to be called a
liar would be to stop lying constantly
she did an interview on Fox News Sunday
night she said both that she is upset
people call her a liar and told that the
obvious blatant brazen bold-faced lie
that Donald Trump reads more than anyone
that she knows now of course it's widely
known that Trump doesn't
there is not a single book that Donald
Trump even claims to have read in the
last 30 years other than I guess his own
book art of the deal which I doubt he
actually read and the Bible which he
definitely didn't read and mentioned
only to appeal to evangelical voters
during his campaign so let's go to the
video check out what Sarah Huckabee
Sanders said in this total softball
pathetic excuse for an interview for
which interviewer Steve Hilton should be
ashamed but I'm sure he's not take a
look it's not
I mean I've watched this process play
out so many times set in hundreds of
meetings with the president and the idea
that he can only take in one or two
bullets is absurd I've watched him
consume massive amounts of information
process it so he doesn't read briefings
and whatever how does he breathe more
than anybody I know every single foreign
trip we actually would laugh about the
fact he has boxes upon boxes file boxes
where he reads for hours the rest of us
want to take a break we want to sleep
and the president works the entire time
he will spend hours on the plane reading
through notes reading through newspapers
magazines he consumes a massive amount
of information at the end she's stored
of hints at the truth which is he's not
reading she mentions magazines
he's haphazardly paging through
magazines probably looking for pictures
of himself and headlines that's not
reading Sarah I hate to break it to you
maybe where she comes from or how she
was raised that counts as reading but
that's not reading in any real sense of
the word meanwhile she's upset that
people call her a liar regularly you're
lying all the time the reason she's
called a liar is that she lies
constantly but not even in ways that are
believable in ways that are completely
obviously untrue lies about something
less well-documented or that are less
obviously a lie maybe could get by but
when you're lying about something that
is so widespread right there's
widespread reporting about how aids had
to reduce Donald Trump's briefing to a
few bullet points with a picture or a
graph or a map or two Trump when he was
presented with lots of text to read
would yell and get angry about handing
documents once reported
saying these are just words a bunch of
words it doesn't mean anything and
throwing the papers back on the table in
front of him if you're reading you don't
refer to reading material as just words
that's not something that voracious
readers tend to do and let's even go
further Trump only seems semi-literate
literate he seems we've done deep dives
into this and he has limited reading
ability this is not saying that he is
illiterate what I'm talking about is
when you don't read for decades and we
know he doesn't use computers he would
negotiate deals on the phones he doesn't
there's no books that we can say with
certitude that Donald Trump is read when
you don't read for decades and by that I
mean you sit down with at least semi
dense material you go through it
sequentially building your knowledge of
the material and integrating it
assimilating it into your pre-existing
knowledge you lose that ability there's
no this isn't even special about Donald
Trump there's no way that the brain can
maintain its ability to assimilate
complex information the kind that a
president would consume under normal
circumstances if you don't do it for
decades and remember that Donald Trump's
co-writer of art of the deal really the
writer Trump told him stories and he
wrote the book he said the entire time
that he worked on the book with Donald
Trump he never saw Donald Trump pick up
a single book he didn't see a book
anywhere around Donald Trump there's
this report of Trump keeping a book of I
think it was Hitler's speeches on his
bedside table who knows if he even
actually read it I would be shocked if
he did if Sarah Huckabee Sanders wants
to stop being called a liar stop telling
obvious brazen demonstrable lies and the
allegations about lying all the time
would stop pretty quickly